Chad GPT today has incredible
capabilities it is like an engineer who
helps you write a video game it is like
a scholar who helps you write a paper
and it is like an assistant who
organizes your life and files dear
fellow Scholars this is two minute
papers with Dr Caro today large language
model assistants understand text and
they understand images they have for
quite a while now however connecting the
two Still Remains a challenge but with
GPT 4's Vision model we can dump all
this information into a robot and it
will be able to take commands from us
and make a plan and perform it and it
gets better it promises that it also has
some common sense something that is not
common at all in today's world so can it
deliver on these promises let's see to
together through three experiments
experiment one here we would like to get
some Coke but
look there is no Coke anywhere to be
seen now's your time to shine little Ai
and then nice it opens the fridge very
gently gu the
coke closes the fridge and there we go
excellent it can also do similar other
gentle tasks such as get some Pringles
and pour it onto a plate experiment two
pick up the Marvel model it is of course
behind a strategically placed glass and
without additional instructions it puts
it away safely and now we can play great
now Experiment three this is a bit
harder perhaps organize the sushi pieces
to be like they are in this image a
tricky multimodal question
can it do it oh yes well done little AI
now two good news and one bad news good
news number one yes this one is also
doing one of my favorites and that is
learning safely in a computer simulation
first and only when it demonstrated that
it is smart and safe can it move around
in the real world good news number two
this can perform all of these tasks in a
zero shot manner this means that it can
perform a broad spectrum of these
everyday tasks without being
specifically trained for it what does
that mean exactly well if you give it a
task that it hasn't seen before it can
lean on its knowledge of the world a bit
like a human would and have a good
chance of still being able to do it if
you ask me that is one possible
definition of intelligence now less good
news not even this technique is perfect
look Chain of Thought this means that
with the prompts it gets a little help
at the risk of simplifying this help
comes in the form of a few examplars
that outlines the reasoning process for
a few tasks for the AI to lean on it's
not that bad and I bet that just one
more paper down the line and this might
not even be needed but today Chad GPT
can do so much more for instance he here
it helps this fellow scholar write a
video game without the user having to
write a single line of code first we
need to briefly describe the game and it
gets to work and then the first version
is already playable excellent wait the
missiles are not exploding so is the
dream over of course not look after
taking a couple screenshots of the game
don't forget GPT is multimodal it can
look at images and then we can explain
the issues we need some explosions
Collision detection and look at that a
significantly better game in a matter of
seconds explosions are now happening now
add the scoreboard to the game a start
screen and a damage SL Health System it
now explains what it is about to do and
there we go a proper little arcade game
this is like having a super fast super
smart engineer at your fingertips this
is absolutely incredible this is not
only an engineer but it can explain
mathematical jokes this is one of my
favorites this one is about explaining
the difference between discrete and
continuous mathematics love it but wait
it's not only good for explaining
mathematical jokes but also for doing
mathematics and writing papers take this
from one of the best mathematicians in
the world today Terence tow even he is
using gp4 and he says as follows quote I
could feed gp4 the first few PDF pages
of a recent math preprint and get it to
generate a half dozen intelligent
questions that an expert attending a
talk on the preprint could ask also
quote I plan to use variants of such to
prepare my future presentations or to
begin reading a technically complex
paper whoo one of the finest
mathematicians of our generation is
asking it for help and gets meaningful
questions and sometimes answers but wait
a second does that not sound like a
helpful colleague or co-author to you
well hold on to your papers fellow
Scholars because here comes the
bombshell quote when integrated with
tools such as formal proof verifiers
internet search and symbolic math
packages I expect say 2026 level AI when
used properly will be a trustworthy
co-author in mathematical research and
in many other fields as well wow and we
are not done yet not even close I have
one more amazing application for you it
can also take a bunch of your files and
take some work off of your shoulders by
once again using common sense and
checking them into the appropriate
directories clut is now gone now of
course this workflow is not as
convenient as it could be yet but just
imagine if this kind of useful tool
could be integrated deeper into the
operating system and not have to work
outside of it that would help us spend
less and less time on organizing in
things and create and learn something
new instead love it so good so fellow
Scholars what you are seeing here is
perhaps the birth of a new tool that
might become more useful than any other
tool I have ever seen wow what a time to
be alive when I was a PhD student my
experiments created lots of data for my
deep learning projects but I was not
looking for more data I was looking for
insights this is what weights and biases
does and it is the best everyone is
using it try it out now at wb. me/
papers or click the link in the
description below